(upbeat instrumental music)
- It's great to see so many people here.
I'm so happy that we have a good turnout
for our distinguished speaker, Talal Asad,
and it's my great pleasure
and distinct honor
to present him to you.
He joins a long list, you
heard some of the names,
of illustrious foster lecturers.
Dr. Assad received his master's degree
from Edinburgh University
and his doctorate at Oxford.
After seven years
teaching in Great Britain,
he moved to the United States
where he joined faculties,
first at the New School
for Social Research
and then at Johns Hopkins University.
For the past decade,
he's occupied a position
as distinguished professor of anthropology
at the Graduate Center of the
City University of New York.
Dr. Assad has been a visiting professor
at universities around the world,
including to our great
benefit and pride, our own,
so this is a revisit
for him to our campus.
Talal Asad is a prolific
writer, the author of six books
and numerous shorter works.
More than four decades
of productive scholarship
have earned him a well-deserved place
in the canon of required reading
for anyone interested in
comparative religious studies.
Among his most celebrated
publications are:
Anthropology and the Colonial
Encounter, published in 1973,
Genealogies of Religion,
published in 1993,
Formations of the Secular, 2003,
and just last year, On Suicide Bombing.
Dr. Asad's work is essential
for an understanding
of the relationship between
the sacred and the secular,
the private and the public,
tradition and modernity.
He has made major contributions
to our knowledge of
Christianity and Islam,
both historically and contemporaneously.
Devoted to translating and demystifying
spiritual beliefs and
behavior, Dr. Asad's work
builds an intellectual bridge
between followers of distinct
religious communities.
Having grown up and studied
in both the Middle East
and the west, he is in
a privileged position
to address questions of
religious coexistence
and conflict past and present.
Dr. Asad's work consistently demonstrates
an erudite and creative
interweaving of history,
sociology, anthropology, and philosophy.
Above all, he is unfailingly informative,
interesting, and provocative.
Dr. Asad speaks to us today on the topic
thinking about religion,
belief, and politics.
Please join me in giving a
warm welcome to Dr. Talal Asad.
(audience applauding)
- Thinking about religion,
belief, and politics
and it is really an attempt to think
rather than to present
any kind of complete
and determined position.
Since the closing decade
of the millennium,
social friction generated by the presence
of substantial numbers of
Muslim immigrants in Europe
and the threat of Muslim
terrorists have given a new impetus
to the fear of politicized religion.
Violent and intolerant
fundamentalist movements
have emerged, not only
in the Muslim world,
although these are the most
frightening in the west,
but also in India, Israel,
and the United States.
The secular values of liberal
democracy are under siege
or so much of the western media tell us.
Academics who teach religious studies
have responded eagerly
seeing in this an opportunity
to demonstrate the public
relevance of their expertise.
What is to be done about the dangers
to liberal democracies
of religious belief?
But tonight I want to begin
with a prior question,
one which I've addressed before
and I'll go over some of the points.
What is religion?
How has it come to be
defined in the ways it has?
Why is belief so strongly emphasized
in so many definitions?
I'll then go on to speculate
about it's connections
with politics, mainly through a discussion
of some shifts in perspective
in the anthropological study
of ritual and religion.
But, I'll also discuss Charles Taylor's
recent magnum opus, A Secular Age,
that draws strategically,
but very importantly, on anthropology.
On Victorian ideas of the primitive mind,
as well as on recent ideas about ritual.
This is a generous and learned work,
full of insight of the
kind we've come to expect
from this philosopher, but I
want to try and think beyond it
and I'll do so by stressing
the body as the site of senses
and sensibilities in
religion and politics.
And I'll end by drawing
on an ethnographic work
on religion and politics
that is a counterpoint
to Taylor's epic, and this
is by an anthropologist
who is actually a Berkeley anthropologist,
Charles Hirschkind,
The Ethical Soundscape.
Now, skeptics have long written about
the origin of religion,
however for most of them
it was not the idea of
religion that was puzzling,
only its emergence was.
At least since the Enlightenment
one important approach
to understanding religion
has consisted in what anthropologists call
the sociology of error.
The main question was what gave rise
to such patently false
beliefs in the first place?
The testing of belief
propositions in this area,
and thus their falsification,
tends to depend
on a highly simplified language ideology
that predicates both the
counterintuitive character
of religious belief statements
and the emotional character
of religious conviction.
The sociology of error,
invented by Victorian anthropologists
for understanding religion,
eventually gave place
to another approach in
which a different set
of questions was raised.
Is religion the universal?
What kinds of belief practice
are peculiar to religion?
Do religious beliefs and
practices give meaning to life,
if so, what kind of meaning?
Do primitives find psychological comfort
from religious practices when confronted
by an unprecedented natural environment?
And do moderns seek
certainty in religious belief
when they are plunged into bewildering
political economic change?
Anthropologists and others
sought to explain religion
by reference to what I
would call externalities,
that is by looking for
it's social function
or for it's cultural meaning.
The concept of religion and it's history
remained virtually unexamined
in this 20th century approach.
To my knowledge, Wilfred Cantwell Smith's
The Meaning And End Of Religion in 1962
was the first book to
present a historical sketch
of a concept of religion in the west.
The first to suggest that
it was relatively recent.
He also argued perceptibly
against essentialist approaches
and yet in the end he
didn't quite break free
of a residual essentialism himself.
Smith sought to substitute
the word faith for religion
in order to avoid the
dangers of reification.
But what this move led to was an emphasis
on an ineffable experience
as opposed to relationships
created through, maintained by,
and expressed in practices
of various kinds.
It's not that there's
anything wrong in my view
in stressing the
importance of inner states
when discussing religion,
even when describing
non modern religiosity.
What's questionable I think
is making a particular language game
in which an apparently unmediated
inner life articulates faith.
The basis of a universal
conception of religion
as when he writes and I quote from him
"my faith is an act that I
make myself naked before God."
The reason I think there can't be
a universal conception of religion
is not because religious
phenomena are infinitely varied
and certainly not because
there's no such thing as religion
as some have suggested, it's that defining
is a historical act and when
the definition is deployed
it does different things
in different times
and circumstances and responds
to different questions,
needs, and pressures.
Although what's marked for
devout practitioners as religion,
it relates to what is essential for them
at the level of scholarly analysis.
It has no essence I would say, and by this
I don't mean that things
don't hang together
in distinctive, even necessary ways
in particular religious traditions,
but only that these are altered over time.
To define is to repudiate some things
and to endorse others.
Defining what is religion is not merely
an abstract intellectual exercise,
it's not just what anthropologists
or other modern scholars do.
The act of defining religion,
and this is forgotten sometimes
even by religious scholars,
scholars of religion,
I beg your pardon, not
the same thing at all,
it's not just what religion
or what anthropologists
and other modern scholars do,
the act of defining religion
is embedded in passionate
disputes connected with anxieties
and satisfactions affected
by changing conceptions
of knowledge and interest
related to institutional disciplines.
In the past, colonial
administrations used definitions
of religion to control and regulate
the practices of their subjects.
Today, liberal democracy
is required to pronounce
on the legal status of such definitions
and thus to spell out
immunities and obligations.
Definitions of religion does
have profound implications
for the organization of social life
and the possibilities
of personal experience.
And yet, for this very
reason academic expertise
is often invoked in
the process of arriving
at legal decisions about religion.
In short, universal
definitions of religion
divert us from asking questions
about what the definition
includes and what it excludes,
Why, by whom, and with what consequences.
Popular debunkers and
defenders of religion
very often tend to anchor their polemics
in clear-cut definitions.
They are uninterested in how
diverse religious notions
do different things in
people's ordinary lives,
in how the human
sensorium, seeing, hearing,
and so forth, articulates experience
recognized as religious
or called non-religious.
They don't ask in what historical
context, to what audience
the act of defining particular
practices as religious
makes or fails to make good sense.
Liberal critics and defenders of religion
have nevertheless argued with one another
over its implications for
modern ethics and politics.
Central to both sides of the debate,
is the notion I think of belief.
Regarded at once as a privilege,
that is the subjects ability
to choose her beliefs
and a danger, beliefs'
incitement to violence.
A first step towards
understanding this convergence
between both positions is to review
the classical Lockean
doctrine of religious freedom
that set some of the
main ideological terms
for this argument.
Those of you who are very familiar with it
will forgive me if I just
go through very briefly
one or two points here,
which are important
for what I want to say.
According to the modern
conception of religion
belief can't be coerced
because it's located
in a private mental space.
This of course is the core
of John Locke's theory
of toleration and one part of
the genealogy of secularism.
The theory rests on a
new religious psychology
that was beginning to emerge
in 17th century Europe.
This allowed Locke to
insist that the princes
attempt to coerce religious belief,
including belief in the
salvational implications
of religious practices, was
irrational because impossible.
All that force could secure
was an insincere profession of
faith and outward conformity.
Therefore, so the argument
went and still goes,
force employed by civil
government should be directed
only at securing objective
public interests,
the protection of life, limb, and property
as the famous phrase has it.
In fact, it's precisely
because the mind is seen
as the impregnable bastion
of true religious experience
that the modern argument
regarding the impossibility
of controlling belief from
outside acquires plausibility.
Some liberal philosophers have countered
the awkward example of
brainwashing by arguing
that it merely creates inauthentic belief
however sincerely that belief may be held.
Authenticity they argue,
consists in the subject's ability
to choose her beliefs and to act on them.
In this fashion, belief
reinforces the idea
of an autonomous subject,
but does the insistence
that authentic belief
is quite different from a sincere
and yet inauthentic belief
mean that the act of saying
something passionately
without choosing should
be pronounced inauthentic?
And I'm not sure that it should.
When somebody takes up a stubborn position
because as they put it famously
because there is no moral alternative,
I can do no other, in the
famous phrase of Luther's.
Should we say they are being inauthentic?
I don't think this strikes,
at least it doesn't strike me
as being somehow quite right.
External forces can not
only compel subjects
to do or to refrain from doing things,
but beliefs too, in my view,
can be imposed by indirect means.
So although the insistence that beliefs
can not be changed from outside
appeared to be saying something empirical
about personal belief,
it's singular, autonomous,
and inaccessible to other location,
it was really part of a political
discourse about privacy,
a claim to civil immunity.
But the claim tended
by and large to be made
against the state and
still to some extent does,
not against the market
where political economic seduction
is typically transmuted
into internal compulsions.
We don't think of that as being
somehow an imposition
and that's interesting.
In his acclaimed book A Secular Age,
Charles Taylor has recounted a story
that seeks to vindicate both
the historical emergence
of the secular democratic order
and the promise of liberal religion.
Although there's virtually
nothing in the book itself
on the liberal democratic state as such,
but there is in his other
some in his other writings.
Contemporary western
christianity as he puts it
clearly depends on it.
The most important sense of belief
sought by liberal
religion is private belief
that is protected by the liberal state.
Taylor's first chapter opens
with the following statement:
"One way to put the question
I want to answer here
in this book is this:
Why was it virtually impossible
not to believe in God
in say 1500 in our western society,
while in 2000 many of us find this
not only easy, but inescapable."
If there is a single condition,
and that's the quote from,
that's the sentence from Taylor.
If there is a single
condition that can be said
to sum up the modern
character belief for Taylor
it's that individual
believers are now confronted
by the distinction between
experience and its construle.
He thinks this is a particularly modern,
don't quite agree with that,
but still that's an important distinction.
This distinction makes
religious belief private,
that is one may entertain
doubt and uncertainty
as well as optional, one can choose.
So these are the two
aspects that were absent
according to him in the pre-modern world.
A secular liberal state is necessary
if these conditions of belief
are to be defined and protected.
Taylor isn't primarily
concerned with beliefs
as propositions that
people hold to of course,
his interest is in what he
calls social imaginaries
or what anthropologists call social myths
that undergird these beliefs.
His interest is in telling the story
of how I quote again from him
"the whole context of understanding
in which our moral, spiritual,
or religious experience
takes place is gradually changed."
Spiritual experience according to him
is a matter of being directly
in touch with transcendence,
that offers itself as a source of meaning
and gives the individual what
he calls a sense of fullness.
When unbelievers feel
that life lacks meaning
the result is a characteristically
secular unhappiness
that Taylor calls a modern malaise.
Yet in modern society, I
would suggest Christians
and non-christians,
believers and non-believers
all live more or less the same life
within the capitalist system.
But if they share, given
class differences of course
and so on, but if they share
a style of private life
and a distinctive relation
to public politics,
how does belief distinguish them?
As I understand Taylor,
it's the modern western
individual's ability
to interpret experience that
leads to different beliefs.
Taylor recognises the plurality of beliefs
as an inescapable modern fact
and affirms the right to
individual interpretation
as a transcendent liberal value.
And although belief in his
story is not to be equivalent
in some simple way to a
proposition as I said already,
the centrality of
construle or interpretation
by what he calls the
buffered self in this account
which is counter posed to
the pre-modern porous self,
brings it pretty close to something
that is capable of being
stated I would argue,
if not propositionaly, then
in the form of a narrative.
Taylor's narrative promises
the unhappy conscience
the possibility of redemption
by religious belief.
A self that seeks to be redeemed
regards it's life as a narrative,
a life that takes the
form of a personal quest.
But there's no redemption
for disrupted selves
in his account.
Taylor's narrative of how a reformed
and disciplined Christianity got here
by traversing overlapping
social imaginaries
is itself an attempt
at narrative coherence
in which some things are repressed
and others are emphasized.
One can see why individual belief
as a choice by right, not
the content of beliefs,
but the fact of belief is
so central to Taylor's story
about the secularization of religion
and why the Christian
promise of personal salvation
finds a place in his optimism
about liberal politics.
Perhaps one might also see why Taylor
is so scornful of attitudes
that regard modernity
non-teleologically as having a tragic
because irresolvable character
and why he sets aside disruption
as offering a creative opportunity.
There's no mention in Taylor's
story of the global crises
that threatened the world today.
Interestingly enough, climate change,
the militarization of
space, economic collapse,
this was written before the
present crisis by the way,
economic collapse, it
wasn't too hard to do that,
nuclear proliferation, war, and terrorism.
And the widening gap
between the wealthy few
and the many poor.
The word crisis appears in his entire text
which is of 900 pages long or thereabouts,
appears in that text only in reference
to the loss of personal
meaning for believers
and for felt need for an absent narrative.
But what's this to do
with religion you may ask?
Well, the answer is
nothing, that is nothing
if religion is to be defined essentially
as a matter of belief
in personal salvation.
And yet, one wonders what happens
to the possibility of narrating the self
if the world in which
the believing subject
must live is seriously imperiled,
and there's no discussion
of that unfortunately.
Since the beginning of
western scholarly interest
in the subject, ethnographic reports
have played an important part
in helping to construct the
object of religious studies.
Taylor himself draws
generously on anthropology,
so let me turn to some debates
on the concept of religious belief.
Among anthropologists,
it was Rodney Needham
who first critically examined
how anglophone ethnographers identified
the religious beliefs of
the people they studied.
What exactly he asked is
being presented to the reader
when the ethnographer
claims to be writing about
the interior state of believers.
His answer was a skeptical one
because these states aren't
necessarily expressed
socially through language,
there are no inner states
that are universal.
Not everyone found this answer conclusive,
but Needham did point to
something of central importance
to the whole enterprise
of comparative religion.
And that is translation,
not only from one language
to another, but also across
two different modalities,
that is the interior and the exterior.
Several anthropologists
who subsequently address
the question of belief did so with respect
to the universalism
versus relativism debate
in which the concern remained cognitive
and primary intention was paid
to implicit meanings in ritual.
For example, Malcolm Ruel,
writing on the Christian
creed in a widely read article
observed and I quote from him
that "The performance of
the Creed is as complex,
symbolic, and condensed an act of ritual
as any other liturgical
act and is consequently
as much subjected to
the categories developed
for example by Turner,
for the analysis of ritual symbolism."
The Christian creed Ruel pointed out
combines two senses of belief.
Belief in a divine
person, the living Christ
and belief that a sacred
event had occurred,
the crucifixion and resurrection.
This echoed an important
historical distinction
between belief as a
relationship of trust, love,
and commitment and belief as a proposition
held in one's mind as true or falsifiable.
Although Ruel doesn't say
so, it should be clear
that whereas the second sense
of belief allows for choice,
the first doesn't do so
or at least not so easily.
Following Needham, we might ask
how we can identify belief
in medieval Latin Christendom?
A society in which it said
that it was almost impossible
not to believe as Taylor famously says.
Recent historical research has shown
that it is not plausible to
regard the medieval period
as a monolithic age of faith.
There's ample evidence
that medieval people
often rejected such orthodox doctrines
as the immortality of the soul,
I'm sorry for this series,
the resurrection, the incarnation,
virgin birth, and purgatory.
The difficulty is that
no ready method exists
for deciding whether such
rejections simply meant
a total absence of
so-called religious beliefs
or were prompted by alternative beliefs.
The problem is further complicated
by the fact that the vocabulary used
belongs to a very
different semantic field.
Infidelitous was typically
used in secular contexts
such as charters, laws,
and historical narratives.
It usually meant breaking
a contract or an oath,
acting in a disloyal manner,
or breaching someone's trust.
Infidelities were not simply
those who fail to hold
Orthodox convictions, they
were first and foremost
those who acted disloyally in some way
or those who through acts
of treason or misfortune
were no longer a part of the
relation that bound together
God, Latin Christians, and
their king, one to another.
Credere, the word in Christian latin
that's translated into
english as to believe
usually as a moral rather
than an epistemological sense
meaning to trust someone more often
than to be convinced about
the truth of a proposition.
As the medievalist Dorothea Weltecke
cites the case of Aude
Fauré, a young peasant woman
who was brought before the Inquisition.
She was unable she said to credere indo.
The detailed context makes it quite clear
that what she meant was
not belief in the sense
that we would now translate it.
She took the existence
of a God for granted.
It was precisely because
in her desperation
she couldn't see in the
eucharist anything but bread
and because she found herself struggling
with disturbing thoughts about incarnation
that she had no hope of God's mercy
and that is what she meant when she said
she didn't as it were,
what we would translate
as believe in God.
My point is simply that
the words then in use,
and this applies to
other cultures as well,
that we now translate
as belief and unbelief
should not be regarded as
epistemological concepts
that define objects of choice,
so important for us in our modern culture.
Both words expressed
emotional dispositions
embedded in social and
political relationships
as well as distinctive sensibilities.
What's changed is the
hierarchy of the senses
I'd suggest, that links human
practices to one another
and to their natural environment.
A change in what Wittgenstein
called a way of life
and ways of life don't change as easily
as ideas in one's head.
I will return to this point later,
but first I want to say
something about ritual,
a kind of practice that's
often been seen by critics
as symbolic activity and by many critics
as activity with an
anti-democratic implication.
This is just ritual as the saying goes.
Anthropologists studying
religion have been interested
not only in religious doctrines,
they have also written
about religious practices.
Like other Victorians,
evolutionary anthropologists
tended to interpret as
magical ways of coping,
rites as magical ways of
coping with difficulties
of the natural environment.
Protestant theologians,
who were also students
of primitive religion, such
as the famous Robertson Smith,
both an anthropologist and a theologian,
took the view that true
Christianity required
that he'd be stripped of Catholic magic,
that is of false science.
But later anthropologists saw all this
as a methodological mistake.
Rituals they maintained,
were not to be regarded
as primitive ways of adjusting to nature,
not as evidence of primitive minds.
As actions, rituals had a
social function of their own.
Some anthropologists like Edmund Leach
proposed the idea that rituals
weren't instrumental actions at all.
Rituals symbolized something,
communicated cultural meaning.
But for Victorian evolutionists,
as well as for many of their
anthropological successors,
the modern notion of belief
attributed to what used to
be called primitive peoples
was essential to their
conception of ritual.
Whether it took the form of a cosmology
or culturally defined norms,
whether it was to be
reconstructed from explanations
offered by practitioners
or read into social actions
and arrangements by
resort to western theories
of signification, belief was central
to the repetitive
activities classed as rites.
Scarcely any anthropologist in my view
took Needham's worries about
beliefs as an interface
between inner and outer seriously.
However, some anthropologists
who now wrote about ritual
took the communicative perspective
in an interesting direction.
Thus, Morris Bloch took
linguistic performance itself
as the paradigm of symbolic action
and argued that the very
formality of oratory,
as in a formality of polite manners,
was a crucial means of social control
and political domination.
Formal communication
including religious ritual
and political oratory was to be seen
as the denial of choice,
one was forced into a
certain form he argued
in this kind of paradigm,
and that therefore it meant
submission to traditional authority.
And traditional authority in
Max Weber's influential view
was one of the three modes
of legitimate domination
as many of you will know.
This approach to ritual
therefore reinforced the idea
that the autonomous
subject needed to break
from tradition and the
repetition of the past
it demanded from him or her.
The claim that ritual had a
repressive social function
resonated with the view
that liberal religion
should primarily take the
form of private belief
with a strong Protestant
rejection of Catholic ritualism.
It reinforced the well-known notion
that ritual was not only non-rational
but also anti-political in the sense
of politics that liberal democracy values,
including the principles of equality,
the freedom to choose,
and the right to free speech and so on.
However, the notion that
formality is necessarily
an external form of
coercion is questionable.
It's only when forms become elements
in a goffmaneque strategy that they serve
as a means of control over others.
Goffman was also another person from here
I remembered suddenly.
But to the extent that
public forms contribute
to the making and remaking
of the self in a social world
to cultivating it where in other words
external forms are part
of the developing self
it's effects will be different.
In that context, what the embodied self
learns to say and do, how it handles
behavioural and verbal forms
in relationship to others
at the center of the
selves moral potentialities
and not merely externally imposed.
In short, if we think of ritual
not as a mode of denying choice of belief
by means of imposed formalities,
but as developing aptness
of behavior, sensibility,
and attitude by means of a learned grammar
then I think come to a
more useful understanding.
Thus, contrary to Bloch's thesis
that the repetition of forms,
that's the condition of formality itself,
is necessarily repressive, one can see
that formality requires not
only repetition of past models
but also the creativity
that issues from judgment
of it's present relevance.
The cultivation of forms is thus necessary
to the cultivation of ethical virtues.
In my mind it was Marcel Mauss
who in his famous essay
entitled Body Techniques
offered the most fruitful
insight into the study of ritual.
And he began from the obvious fact
that the educated body achieved
a range of human objectives
from styles of physical
movement, walking for example,
through modes of sensibility
and two kinds of spiritual experience.
Mauss was not interested in the divide
between religion and secularity.
He had no investment in
constructing a category
called religion as a component
of a universal called religion.
His interest was in the
formation of attitudes
both sacred and profane.
Most importantly, he showed a way
of asking different questions
than the ones focused on belief.
In the final paragraph to that essay,
Mauss wrote famously, I
have quoted this before,
"I believe precisely that there are,
even at the base of all
our mystical states,
body techniques which
have not been studied,
but which were fully
studied in China and India
ever since ancient times.
This socio, psycho, biological study
should be made, he goes on to say,
I think there are
necessarily biological means
of entering into communion with God."
This is still Mauss, not me.
That biological means of
entering into communion with God.
Now, Mauss isn't saying of
course that that experience
can be explained biologically,
but only that the inability
to enter into what people
have called communion with God
or the inability to revere
words, things, and persons
associated with him may be the function
of inexperienced bodies,
of bodies for whom certain
kinds of experiences
have been made difficult,
if not impossible.
For Mauss, belief was not
a matter of construing
and choosing, but of the
mode in which the human body
conscious as well as unconscious, exists.
To put this point in less invidious terms,
one might say that the secular
attitude and experience
like the religious
requires particular social,
psychological, biological conditions,
I'm using Mauss's phrase,
that the distinctive attitudes
underlying secularism as
a political arrangement
presuppose particular
hierarchies of the senses.
Some culturally valorized senses
are deliberately encouraged
as objects of disciplinary projects.
Others emerge out of the convergence
of various political economic developments
and the regulatory strategies
that they give rise to
in modern industries, mass
markets, cosmopolitan cities,
modern transport and communications,
capitalist corporations,
and modern warfare.
Social imaginaries in other words,
as a set of pre-reflective
assumptions and beliefs
don't seem to me to be quite explanatory
of the historical shift from
a so-called believing culture
imposed and maintained
by traditional authority
to one that's free and
predominantly unbelieving
because explanations in
terms of social imaginaries
subsumes, as Taylor himself has argued,
subsumes lower order desires
which are raw and corporeal
within higher order desires
which are construed, that is
interpreted and evaluated,
so that those lower order
desires are actually organized
by the higher order
desires according to him.
And this seems to me to underestimate
the contingency of bodily senses.
In other words, the
notion of social imaginary
and the associated notion of construal
seemed to me to fail to get
at the unpredictable shifts
and distortions in social
life that are independent
of the criteria for
interpreting experience
and of a coherence sort in narrative.
To explore connections of
religion belief and politics
we need to ask a number of
questions about the body
I think, it's senses and it's attitudes.
For this we need ethnographies
of the human body,
its attitudes to pain, physical
damage, decay, and death
as well as to bodily integrity,
growth, and enjoyment
to isolation from and
strong connection with
other persons and things.
Attitude incidentally seems to me
to be less intellectualist
and more practical
than our modern overstretched word belief.
What architecture of the senses,
hearing, seeing, smelling,
touching, tasting
do particular attitudes and
sensibilities depend on?
How do new sensory perceptions take shape
and make older ways of
engaging with the world,
that's building experiences
and older political forms,
not merely wrong but irrelevant?
The work of Walter Ong especially,
and I won't mention them, but anyway,
his work is relevant to these questions
because he was among the
first to trace shifts
from the reliance on hearing
to primary emphasis on seeing.
Ong has rightly been criticized
for recounting an overly simple
story of historical stages
in the development of human communication
from oral culture through
alphabet and print
to the electronic media.
In fact, both in the past and
today, orality and writing
have been intertwined in complicated ways.
Let me give you one example
from the Islamic scriptural tradition
in which the senses of hearing and seeing,
reading and reciting
are closely intertwined.
Te Quran, which as many of you know
means literally recitation,
is deeply rooted
in complex continuities,
quite apart from the major schools
that have provided it
with it's construles.
The earliest text written in
a primitive seventh century
Arabic script seems to have been treated
as a kind of musical score,
a prompt for the oral rendition
that depended on memorization
through reiteration.
Sign and sound went together,
but not in any direct or fixed way.
It was only because the oral
traditions were continuous
that they were able to
provide an imminent frame
for the written text
and thus, for its scholarly
reception over the centuries.
An effort has always been required
to abstract the Quranic text
as an intellectual object
consisting of statements
or even narratives
from the relationship
between the charged sound
and the attentive body
with its growing store of memorizations.
The historian Alain Corbin
has taken up the question
of changing perceptions of the world
appropriated by different human senses,
hearing, seeing, smelling, in detail.
In his fascinating study,
The Foul and the Fragrant,
he traces the densely
interwoven discourses
on the cramped condition
of the urban masses.
The conditions of contagious disease
and the practices of individual hygiene
in 18th and 19th century French society.
One eventual consequence Corbin observes,
was an added emphasis on
the priority of clear sight
and I quote "there was
increased concern for light
in private dwellings as in public spaces.
This was the beginning of
the great swing in attitudes
that was to give supremacy,
he writes, to the visual.
Darkness made nocturnal
animals sad and perfidious.
Uncertain light was a threat to health,
zeal for work, and sexual morality."
Corbin points out that it was not always
the ideas themselves
that immediately changed,
but rather that the new form of perception
made for what he calls
a new intolerance of
traditional actuality.
Shifts in sensory
perception endow experience
of other people and things
with complicated emotions,
anxieties, and pleasures,
a function not merely of what is sensed,
but of how it's sensed.
The new hierarchy of the senses
associated with new patterns of living
contributed to an aspect
of modern subjectivity
that we might provisionally
identify as secular.
I quote from him again:
"Techniques of ventilation
insofar as they acknowledge
the need for space between
bodies and gave protection
against other people's
odors brought individuals
into a new encounter with
their own bodily smells
and as such, contributed
decisively to the development,
he writes, of a new narcissism."
Now if Corbin is right,
then this narcissism,
this disgust at other
people's bodily odors
and love for oneself in one's own odors
may have reinforced the
feeling that an unwanted touch
by a foreign body, an unwanted
touch by a foreign body,
was a shameful
contamination making a wound
inflicted by another,
yet more of a defilement,
one calling for a vigorous
cleansing response.
So one might turn this around
and ask what kinds of violence
whether individual or
collective can be traced
to this modern narcissism
if in fact we are willing
to go along with this.
And this may help, I think, explain
why the ambitious narcissist
protects his own boundaries
religiously if I may put it that way,
but easily transgresses the
secular boundaries of others.
At any rate, many secular sensibilities
are the unintended consequences
of new sense perceptions
that are themselves part of
the changing ways of life.
Of course, attitudes and sense perceptions
are also deliberately
cultivated in institutions
and social movements,
but the important point
is that the senses are
central to the public life
in which people participate,
to the ways they promote,
submit to, or resist the
forces of political life.
The modern secular state
isn't simply the guardian
of one's personal right
to believe as one chooses,
it's also and first of
all a collective condition
in which one senses and
feels in specific ways.
And yet, the work of the senses
has received less attention than it should
in the study of secular politics.
What has come to be discussed
in increasing detail
is discipline, and I myself
been very interested in that,
discipline in the cultivation
and internalization
of attitudes as well as in the regulation
of individual conduct
by external authorities.
But important though discipline is,
the conscious cultivation
of behavior and belief
isn't quite the same thing
as the unintended shifts
in the sensorium described
by anthropologists
and historians like Corbin.
Thus, in his interesting study of the role
of Calvinist doctrine
and practice in the
formation of the early modern
European State, Philip
Gorski has reviewed a range
of authors who've dealt with
the idea of discipline in ways
that he regards as useful,
but not quite adequate.
His own thesis is that the intensification
of religious discipline
in early modern Europe
helped strengthen the state
in several ways and that
the process of strengthening
was dual in origin, both
from above and below.
Taylor draws in some detail on Gorsky
because he's interested
in the way discipline
has contributed to the
formation of what he calls
a buffered self, an objective
self contained self,
disenchanted and modern,
and able to control
its emotions and feelings, to
separate itself from objects
by contemplation, reasoning,
and interpretation
and to choose from available beliefs.
For Taylor and for others
who have taken this view,
it was the civilizing process
that produced the buffered self
out of the primitive porous self
and thereby gave the world the
gift of individual freedom.
Now this familiar story
about the role of discipline
in the formation of modernity
is one I'm not very comfortable with
because it too often ignores
who is disciplined and how
and fails to pursue all
the effects of discipline
whether intended or not.
But assuming that this is the story,
we encounter an intriguing question
when we consider so-called fundamentalists
in the contemporary Middle East
and I would like to put this to you.
Thus, although in Euro
America the discipline self
or the model or the ideal
of the discipline self
is said to be the distinctive
figure of modernity
and its freedom.
The presence of discipline
in Muslim life generally
and Islamic movements in particular,
is commonly taken as evidence
of precisely its opposite.
The existence of rules of
conduct of dress, comportment,
daily prayers, etc, and the
cultivation of sensibilities,
the control of emotion
in speech and behavior,
and reverence towards the sacred voice,
are seen as constrained and suppression.
This is an example of
precisely what arguments
for toleration warn against if political
or religious authority imposes norms
of conduct and doctrine on the individual
and if this imposition is accepted
then this must be a case of
sincere but inauthentic belief
or what one would call
an ideologically confused consciousness.
Now, I don't want to present
this as a question of bias,
I want to make a rather
different point here.
And this is that one might pursue
a more anthropological question
that instead of approaching such behavior
in terms of belief, and in this
case of inauthentic belief,
and this is obviously what differentiates
these people from us.
Instead of doing that, and because belief
is my quarry as you know here,
one should inquire into
what the behavior does
and how the bodily senses
are cultivated to take shape
in different circumstances
and hence into what politics
this cultivation makes
possible or difficult.
Now this leads me finally to a study
by an anthropologist many of you know
who has tried to formulate his questions
in his ethnography in just this way,
the Ethical Soundscape
by Charles Hirschkind.
And I described it
earlier as a counterpoint
to Taylor's book by which I
meant both that it deals with
a much shorter historical
timespan and a specific location
and that it's more dense in its account
of that time and space.
Hirschkind is less interested
in histories of ideas
than in a way of life.
In this sense he's a better
anthropologist than I am.
More precisely his study asks
how the enormously popular practice
of listening to sermons
in contemporary Cairo
shapes religious sensibilities
and traces some of its
consequences for politics.
Throughout Islamic history
attending the Friday sermon
has been an important part
of Muslim subject formation.
Hirschkind analyzes the
reception of sermons
as an active process one in
which the faithful listener
cultivates her ability
to attend and to which
as in listening to a
piece of demanding music,
belief and meaning are
of little significance,
just as we don't really
say what's the meaning
of this piece of music,
that's one of the points
that he's he's trying
to make about listening.
Listening to sermons in modern Cairo
is no longer confined to the friday mosque
and it's no longer a one-off experience.
Taped sermons are heard numerous times
in many urban contexts, political oratory,
and media entertainment
have affected sermons styles
and so made new connections
with the institutions of national life
as well as with the
transnational Islamic community.
This movement has grown in
response to the Egyptian state's
often violent attempt to
suppress the Muslim Brotherhood
which is very unpopular
in some quarters here
which constitutes the most serious
popular opposition to that state.
Hirschkind's account of the movement
describes how it promotes
an acoustic sensibility
opposed to the state's
obsession with spatial order
as well as to the nouveau
riche who have withdrawn
increasingly into their clean
orderly gated communities
in Cairo as in so many other cities.
Contained in this opposition is a struggle
for defining the scope and sensibility
appropriate to real Islam.
What Hirshkind calls a counterpublic
is thus an Islamic space
of moral distancing
from the hegemonic religious
secular order of the state.
Thus many Islamists regard the
regime of personal discipline
as helping to develop
sensibilities that might moderate
if not totally negate the seductions
of a neoliberal consumer culture.
Since Hirschkind did
his field work in Egypt
an oppositional movement
has emerged in strength
known as Keffiyeh, enough,
that's the name of that movement.
Keffiyeh overlaps with the counter public
and it brings together a
variety of social elements,
Muslims and Christians,
Islamists and secular liberals,
men and women, professionals
and labor unionists
in a coalition against the
authoritarian neoliberal state.
It's not that there's now a happy union
of all these elements, but
that an irreducible plurality
persists as a foundation
of political sensibility.
What gathers secular
liberals and Islamists
and others together despite
a continuing measure
of mutual unease is
precisely not their belief
but their oppositional
attitude, their common feeling
that circumstances in Egypt
have become intolerable.
They speak of their opposition
as something they did not choose
but were compelled to adopt.
However, this situation
isn't merely negative
it also provides a space
of daily interaction
and negotiation whose future nevertheless
remains entirely unclear.
Discrete and not so discrete intrusions
by among other things American power,
as well as the contradictory desires,
feelings, and sensibilities
within individuals
and between them make
a political teleology
virtually impossible.
The religiosity involved
in this movement emerges
as a mode of being that
is inwardly unsettled
yet outwardly civil.
It's never simply a mode of living
where belief can be chosen
together with every other
good in the marketplace.
Instead, there's an attempt
to cultivate a sensibility
attuned to mutual care
among the community.
To what extent this succeeds
or even what its future holds
are of course entirely different questions
and I won't venture into that.
So perhaps the crucial
point for understanding
the threat of religion in
the contemporary world,
the thought with which I began,
isn't the secular
tolerance of pure beliefs,
as is that this is the only
remedy for religious belief
that generates violence.
It's not that conversion to
liberal model of Christianity
provides the best way of
demonstrating the authenticity
of belief for the modern
religious subject.
The interesting point in
my view I would suggest
is that different kinds
of practice encourage
and presuppose particular forms
of what has been called
religious sensibility
and that this relates
in unpredictable ways
to emerging political
and moral possibilities.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat instrumental music)